[Music]
I see a lost soul an insect of no fixed
address an aimless Vagabond hopping from
half to half with no Direction no job no
prospects and no purpose in life now
look here just because Bella sneaks into
somebody's house to warm his backside
and
sure he might have gotten kicked out of
a place or two but
okay you have Point here's the thing do
you know the difference between right
and wrong you darn cute and I do I
consider myself a bug of high moral
standards no matter what you may have
heard well that settles it then Neil Mr
cricket
I hereby appoint you Pinocchio's
conscience uh temporary conscience sure
temporary conscience until such time as
Pinocchio May grow his own
henceforth you are the high Keeper of
the knowledge of right and wrong and a
trusted counselor during moments of
Temptation
[Music]
arise
it's a Jiminy Cricket
this is more like it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
I present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only being
[Applause]
hello Pops
Keepers and almost real boy
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
I will be right here when you get back
Pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody wants to be a somebody
that I want to be real why on Earth
would you want to be real when you can
be famous
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
by now
he won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
be brave
truthful non-selfish
[Music]
you'll always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person panels
what's happening Jiminy looks like some
sort of fairy magic
kinda on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
good